autre priorité devrait être de rétablir
des frontières en france et de poser des
frontières à l'europe voulait dépossédé
les peuples notre peuple du droit
légitime d'être est de demeurer lui-même
demain l'europe sera t-elle encore
l'europe si comme à cologne les journées
sont rythmées par l'appel du muezzin
sera t-elle encore l'europe si comme
dans des villes belges et hollandaises
une majorité d'habitants prêtent
allégeance au roi du maroc ou au sultan
erdogan enfin si comme tant de quartier
de france une autre civilisation
s'impose et avec elle un rapport aux
femmes qui nous est étranger
l'europe survivre à des déficits
supérieurs à 3% du pib mais elle ne se
relèverait pas d'un déficit de prolonger
des naissances compensée par des
migrations extérieur les nations
d'europe ne veulent être ni 10 août ni
remplacer ni submergé
élections présidentielles des 10 et 24
avril prochain ne décidera pas seulement
du sort de la france mais de celui de
l'europe toute entière sur le président
de la république comment pouvez-vous
prétendre vous prétendre aujourd'hui en
rassembleur en europe alors que vous
aurez été jusqu'au bout le diviseur de
la france préférant à l'unité du pays la
concurrence généralisée et donc la
guerre de tous contre tous
[Musique]